welcome back everyone uh we're very
happy to have lenka zervova
from uh sakle who's going to give the
the third part of the course scientific
physics and computation in high
dimensions
thanks a lot mikey and it's a real
pleasure to be in this virtual
group at the simons institute
so we already had two parts of this
lecture by floral so this is a
continuation
that will be in a very similar spirit
but about a slightly different graphical
amount
so this is the graphical model that the
lecture will be about
the one of the generalized linear model
so in that graphical model you have
variables w
that we will be considering to have
checks prior if you want pw
that acts component wise at least
in the first two thirds of the talk
and then there is a matrix x that is
connecting those variables to
constraints or checks to which we
associate a label y
and the probability distribution that
these checks
are responsible for is something that
depends on the label y
and on the scalar product of the vector
you know if you connect the elements of
these matrix elements and the vector w
so that's a very generic setting of a
generalized linear model
now the lecture will be about several
cases
of distributions of the data that is
distributions from which the y
and x come from for which we can get
explicit close form solutions for
various quantities that i will mention
in the high dimensional limit when the
number of dimensions p
which is the number of elements of this
this w vector and the number of samples
which is the number of constraints here
three
they both go to infinity with a fixed
ratio that we will call alpha
and so i will just go through i think
five
examples of this setting that you might
find interesting
and then i will go in detail into these
five examples
so in the first three today and in the
second to
tomorrow so the first example
is the problem of perceptron storage
capacity
so that's one of the classical problems
that is statistical physics here i'm
giving you two physics papers from the
80s
where gardner and dorita studied this
problem
so this is the definition of the problem
i will always specify what is the
distribution of
y and x for which we are solving
the problem so in this case the x is
just iid random with zero mean and
you know variance that is proportional
to the demand one over the dimension the
labels are also iid random from the
rather marker distribution so plus minus
1
independent of everything else and the
constraints here are saying
that the scalar product between these
patterns x
these samples and the vector w times
the label y should be bigger than some
constant kappa and
usually we look at commonly we look at
two cases
of in which space the w lives the first
one would be the spherical perceptron
where the w
just lives on a high dimensional sphere
and here i just in two dimensions
illustrate what these constraints are
doing so if i
choose the first sample to be in this
direction
and the corresponding label is y one
the kappa constant here is zero that's
why this is a plane
and kind of this half of the space is
forbidden by this constraint
and if i choose another one then this
half of the space is forbidden
and the w lies on the sphere lives on
the sphere
so it's this part of the sphere
that is still a solution to all the
constraints
and in the binary case it is the same
thing except that the space of w
is just the high dimensional hypercube
so in the two dimensions just these four
points
and if i choose the same labels and the
same data
you know i forbid corresponding half
planes the solution
in this case is the last one remaining
is this green one
so in this problem we are we will be
interested in two things
the storage capacity which will be which
is defined as
the largest ratio between the number of
samples and the dimension so this
constant alpha
such that there exists a w so that all
the constraints can be satisfied
and we will also be interested and if it
is not the case
if not all the constraints can be
satisfied then we will be interested in
the ground state energy which is the
smallest
possible number of unsatisfied
constraints minimized over all the w's
either from the sphere or from the
hypercube
so that will be our first problem the
second one
is the problem of compressed sensing
which i won't really be talking about in
detail but it's this beautiful idea that
if you want to measure
some kind of natural signal such as a
picture when you're doing
an mr scan or or x-ray or something like
that
then you use using the property that
this natural signals can be compressed
you can actually measure them with
number of measurements that rather than
corresponding to the ambient demand to
the number of pixels in the picture
it corresponds to the sparsity so
it rather corresponds to number of
non-zero coefficients under some basis
that makes the picture sparse
that you know mathematically it can be
expressed this way and here you see how
that becomes
the same problem that i'm talking about
so if g
is a measurement matrix of the apparatus
and s star is your signal
and the measurements are y then if you
have a transform here phi
in which you can transform the signal to
make it sparse
the sparse transformation transform
would be this w that you know
sparse meaning that has many zeros
then i can defining this matrix x as
g times phi inverse
i can rewrite this problem using the
previous notation with w
x and y that corresponds to this
graphical model that i have shown you
where again this problem is commonly
studied in the theoretical literature
when the
x is again iid random because that
conserves the information in the
measurements nicely
and the w star this time is commonly
considered sparse so
gauss bernoulli for instance in this
case and the goal is to recover the
unknown w star from the known y and x
the third example we will be looking at
is going towards the direction of neural
networks and
it will be this so far the the so-called
teacher student setting for neural
networks
where a teacher so where we present
iid data x to a
teacher neural network the weights of
that neural network
the ground to weights are chosen again
at random iid from some distribution and
the network generates labels there are
some
activation functions as you want to
choose them and then the student network
for simplicity
can know the architecture of the teacher
network and the activations
but it doesn't know the way it's w star
and from samples x and y
is supposed to learn the weights w star
so this teacher student setting of
neural networks we will be able
again it's formulated via the same
graphical model
in the case where the number of hidden
units so the white
neurons here is k and is order one
while the dimension of the data and the
number of samples both go to infinity
with a fixed ratio again
so that will be a setting in which we
will be looking and going i will also
briefly mention going beyond that but
that's actually a challenge
the fourth example that we will be
looking at
so so far the x was always iid
and the w was coming from a separable
prior in these three examples
different ones but that was always the
case so the fourth example we will go to
a case where the w does not come from a
separable prior
but instead from a separable prior it
actually comes
from a in general deep
generative neural network so
again this is easiest to explain the
interest of that
in some kind of setting where we measure
a signal as star via some
apparatus that corresponds to
multiplying by a matrix
g and there may be some non-linearity
for instance in phase retrieval you
measure only the modulus of
of a complex number and
with respect to the compressed sensing
where we picked a basis in which the
signal as star was sparse
now we compress it or reduce the
dimension but in a different way
you know inspiring ourselves with people
doing generative
deep learning we actually write a
generative network
that on the input has a vector z that
has much smaller dimension
okay in this case then it is the
dimension of s that is p
always for us so k is much smaller we
picture k much smaller than p
so that's another way to compress the
signal and we will be looking how that
changes
with respect to the compre sensing that
uses the sparsity
and you know these these two people here
that's not the outers of the paper as
you could think that's actually
people pictures generated by these by
models of this form so just to show you
that this form is
very generic to to to generate something
very structured and the fifth example
so i was saying you know the canonical
example is iid x
and separable w we will be talking of
non-separable w
and we will also be talking about
nonsense about non-iid
x in the fifth example and kind of the
simple
that you know can the case that we will
be talking about
is can be set as the random feature
learning
so random feature learning you can view
it as
a one hidden layer neural network
where the first layer of weights that
here i denote f
is not learned is just fixed and
here i changed a little bit the notation
for the data the data will be
c here so that i get back to my notation
that i need for the graphical model of
interest
so here imagine that your data is c
the first fixed layer of weights is
f and then the post activations
that you get after the first layer you
call that matrix
x and then the labels y are generated
again via a teacher that acts on the
data that's similar as before
but now you and now you are learning the
way it's w
so that's the same w as before from the
labels y
and from this x that you know because
this
fixed weights f you know them so you can
multiply your data that you know and
obtain that matrix
x so this
this case will also be solvable in a
limit where the dimensions
d and p and go to infinity with the
fixed ratio
and we will actually be more interested
in an
alternative interpretation or different
interpretation of the same mathematical
structure
that we call the hidden manifold model
which really mathematically is exactly
the same thing except that now instead
of saying that we are learning
with random features we are actually
again inspiring ourselves by the fact
that these generative models are very
rich
and that they probably describe the
observed data much better than just
some iid assumption and
then you can think of this data x
as one layer generative model say
decoder of auto encoder or generator of
the gun
and so this is something that we call
the hit manifold mode but mathematically
it's exactly the same thing so if we can
solve the random features we can also
solve this one
so that will be i will be talking about
this tomorrow
but now let's get into some more detail
and start with the example one and go to
two and three that i will be treating
together
and then tomorrow the four and five
so back to the storage capacity so
here is again the definition so that's
the slide you have already seen
where i just want to point to you um
a nice geometric interpretation of what
the storage capacity actually is because
maybe a simpler way to think about it
is that the maximum number of samples
for which this type of
data are still linearly separable and
the w
is then kind of this linear separators
so while there exists a w
so that you know the positive labels are
on one side of that
hyperplane and the negative are on the
other side
then we are below the storage capacity
and when the w doesn't exist anymore we
are above
so so that of course is true when when
the kappa is
zero so then you have this nice relation
to the linear separability which is of
course
interesting in machine learning more in
general
and the way the storage capacity
corresponds to the graphical model it's
really
the generic setting the only thing that
you specify
is that now what used to be some generic
p out the distribution some function
between the labels and the scalar
product
now is very specifically the step
function of
y times this scalar product minus kappa
so if this thing is positive it is one
if this thing is negative it is zero
and then we are looking at the
probability distribution over these
uh w's so what is known about this
problem so this is
a problem that has been studied for for
very long time
so for the spherical perception where
the w lives on a
hypersphere in case of kappa 0
this the storage capacity is 2 and
that's very
well known result of cover in case
that the capacity that this constant
kappa is non-negative
this is one of the well-known you know
one of the first
kind of well-known usage of the replica
method by darida and gardner where they
actually
compute the storage capacity and
and rigorously that formula has been
proven
some 17 years ago by sherpina anterosa
the case where the kappa is negative
was not studied so much in you know in
the
old literature but has been studied in
physics recently
and since in this case those spaces that
you are
that you are putting together they they
the the what is left is not convex
anymore
then you have kind of space for more
interesting things happening
so so in that case it has been computed
predicted there is a replica symmetry
breaking and from the rigorous point of
view really not much
not that much is known in that case so
that's just if you're interested in that
then there is the binary case which is
somewhat more peculiar and and
interesting mathematically
so of course when you're optimizing or
looking at probability distributions
over discrete spaces such as the
hypercube
things get more complicated but not so
much for the replica method so
still late 80s there is a very explicit
prediction
for what is the storage capacity for
this case
which boils down to this expression for
the
replica symmetric free energy that i'm
not deriving here but you really get it
using very much the same calculation
that fluoron was showing in the first
lecture
but it would take maybe like one hour to
actually go through it so
so so i will not be doing that but from
that
replica symmetric free energy you get
the capacity simply by looking whether
it is positive or negative so if
it is positive we are below the capacity
w's exist
and above it is not and the threshold
ends up if you evaluate this ends up
being something like 0.833
and this conjecture is there
for 30 years now from the rigorous point
of view it's quite
challenging in the sense that for very
long time
the only result that was there
to to bound this um storage capacity
was by kim and and roche and kind of you
know
this this bound is not zero is positive
and this bound
is smaller than strictly smaller than
one one is trivial to get so it's it's
non-trivial
but you see it's very far from the
predicted a33
so then our organizers had a very
interesting paper two years ago where
they actually got a tight lower bound
proving kind of this result that
directly comes from the
from the replica method and this there
is an
interesting work on the sharpness of the
threshold but on the upper bound it's
still open
so this you know this is perhaps still
maybe the kind of
simplest problem that is still open that
has a very explicit
uh conjecture very explicit formula so
the case that i like
uh maybe the variant of this problem
that maybe gives some more intuition
is is if instead of the step function as
i was taking so far
so the constraint being that the scalar
product needs to be bigger than some
kappa
if you actually take the variant where
you take absolute value of this color
product
and then you have two cases either you
ask it to be bigger than kappa
or to be smaller than kappa so this
introduces two symmetric variants of
this
of this perceptron problem and in the
binary case when the ws are binary
then this symmetry is kind of
responsible for some simplicity
that if you compute the
just first moment or any yields uh
bound on the gardner capacity which ends
up to be this minus log 2 over logarithm
of a probability that this
that is some simple scalar probability
that you can express then actually this
expression that is never
correct for the step function binary
perceptron
for the symmetric ones actually ends up
to be correct but not always so for the
rectangular one always
because that's the that still ends up
convex but for the other one
where the absolute value is required to
be bigger than some constant which is of
course highly non-convex because you can
be on the two sides
we could predict that for kappa smaller
than some kappa star
this is actually the right storage
capacity
but for kappa bigger than kappa star
it's not
and there again it's an open problem
what it actually is
and we suppose that there is again some
replica symmetry breaking going on and
that's again in the realm of open
problems where we don't really
understand so well what's going on
but let me now go to the question
whether these solutions can be found
efficiently because this lecture is on
high dimensional
problems inc and computation
so from the statistical physics point of
view
things are known but you will see that
the situation is
peculiar it's it's really a peculiar
case the binary
perceptron from the computational point
of view
because so we we know how the solutions
are structured
at least a mass of measure one of the
solutions
and that's in a structure that we call
frozen one rsb
or whatever that's just a term but what
this is
that the solutions are organized in
small blobs of entropy that is not even
extensive
so it's not just one solution it's some
several of them but not extensively
not exponentially many of them and then
these blocks are separated from each
other with extensive distance and there
is nothing in between
and this type of separation in the space
of solutions
is believed to be algorithmically
difficult so it's conjectured that
algorithms cannot find solutions of that
type so of course this is
just the conjecture proving something
like that would be awesome but we are
very far from that
but what's interesting is this third
point
that is basically you know here i cite
one paper by the group of zekina but
they have whole series of works
along those lines where they are showing
that actually
heuristically or empirically numerically
algorithms do find solutions
in the binary perceptron but solutions
that are very different
from the ones that are described by this
by the equilibrium by
those that are the dominant ones and
they argue that there is a rare cluster
of solution rare in the sense that it's
subdominant
that actually is easy to find and
roughly they are able to find it to
alpha something like 0.75 whereas the
threshold is
83. and and that but that's mostly
non-rigor that's not rigorous and mostly
empirical
uh numerical or you know based on some
non-rigorous assumptions
and this i think is a really interesting
you know
what follows from this is that these
algorithms would be actually finding
this rare cluster
but how do you capture that rigorously
so i think this is a really interesting
question and in
answer to sellers email
call for open problems during the
lecture i think i will put
five of them that i think are you know
accessible so this is the first one
like constru show an algorithmically
constructive lower bound
for the binary perceptron that is better
than the one of rohit and
anki so
this you know this might be i don't
think people like
looked at that very deeply so i don't
think it's like over
explored open problem but i think it is
interesting and might be possible
because there might be algorithms that
would be actually hitting this rare
cluster if that cluster actually exists
and that would also be kind of showing
that it exists and already the bound by
kim and roche is probably kind of
showing that it exists
so i think it will be interesting to
discuss along these lines
but that's basically uh what i wanted to
say about the storage capacity just
last two slides to to kind of remind you
that you know while this looks like a
neural network
you know our perceptron with random
labels relevant for learning with neural
networks that's the question of this
slide
so the kind of main answer would be no
because if your labels are random then
generalization doesn't mean anything and
so then you're not learning so then it's
just like a mathematical type problem
so it's not exactly true there are some
nice connections to
that are actually relevant to learning
especially because the gardener capacity
is related to the vc dimension
you can show a bound that the vc
dimension must be bigger than half of
the gardener capacity
but that unfortunately goes kind of in
the wrong direction you would like to
show that the vc dimension is smaller
than something rather than bigger
something so that might be interesting
but it doesn't kind of give anything
relevant for the vc based bounce and
it's also related to the radio macro
complexity so this is something
on this slide that um
that didn't appear surprisingly in kind
of the literature from the 80s 90s even
though it could
so it's something that we realized only
recently
so i will not be explaining what's
radical complexity and what's
what's it used for in learning either
you know or it would be for too long but
for those of you who know
actually notice if you if you take the
definition of radio macro complexity for
this simple
function class that corresponds to the
perceptron
then actually the ground state energy of
the perceptron that i defined
is very trivially related to the
rademacher complexity
so if you can compute the ground state
energy for this function class
you are computing in the you know high
dimension limit that we are at
not just bounding computing the
radiomicrocomplexity
so if you want to read more about that
we wrote recently a paper about that
but of course in this case we don't have
a simple exact expression
for the ground state actually if you
compute the replica symmetric brown
state you see that it's completely off
even the one or one
over square root of n scaling doesn't
pop
out from it but if you do the one step
replica symmetry breaking
uh calculation for the ground state that
is unfortunately not the right one that
you at least get
the right scaling so if we actually
could get the exact result we would have
the exact result for the radar
microcomplexity
so that's another i think remark that
that should be more widely known
but with this i am going to so maybe
that's a good
a good point to to pause for questions
if there are some at this point because
now i will be
switching to the teacher student
generalized linear model for the
for the rest of this dog
so if there are no questions then i will
just go questions will be at the end
so example two and three i'm putting the
compress sensing
in that just changing this just changing
the prior so
so let me say it again was this teacher
student setting for neural network
so here i'm still in the setting where
the x will be iid random
and the w's will be coming from some
separable distribution the ground
through w's and then
generating the labels y and then the
studio network is getting the samples
x and y but not the ground true w's
and it's supposed to uh learn
the w's or other w's but something that
reproduces the
the same y's though the same y's that
you would get from the ground through
w's
we are interested now in the
generalization error not
not any more in satisfaction of
constraints or optimization
the goal here is to learn to generalize
so again as is
you know often the case in my talks you
know this is a problem that in the
physics
was actually in this garner the reader
paper they had model a
and b and c and model b was this teacher
student setting for the perceptron model
so they already defined
and studied this in the in the simplest
case where there are no hidden units
so when we are still in the in the realm
of
uh generalized linear regression so
concretely they study the case where
again the x is gaussian iid w
is taken from some separable prior and
the y's
are a sign of the scarlet product the
labels are are this
and already in the 89 they looked at
this you know
high dimensional regime as as i am
defining it
that kind of became popular in
statistics maybe much
maybe somewhat later so
just one more paper from from that time
that actually solves the teacher student
perceptron in the case of the binary
[Music]
binary teacher weights that again
is interesting because it presents a
phase transition so here is the
generalization error as a function of
this parameter alpha which is how many
samples
you have per dimension and there is a
sharp drop
of that error to zero at a
gardner-darida transition that is 1.24
so
you you just need a bit more samples
than the dimension like 25 percent more
samples than the dimension to be able to
reach
perfect generalization in theory
but do you manage to do that
algorithmically
so that was not so clear back in the 80s
and even in the physics literature
actually this paper has this branch that
is the right answer but they say it's a
non-physical branch that
doesn't mean anything so so kind of
clarifying this whole picture now i'm
jumping 30 years ahead
of what actually we know today about
about this this problem so far without
hidden
uh units that's kind of a paper that has
kind of
rather complete account of what has been
known say two years ago
is this one so what we did there we
generalized this
this theory for any activation functions
and any prior on the weights
and also clarified the relation to the
approximate message passing and the
regions in which the approximate message
passing is optimal and rigorously prove
that those replica results are actually
correct
so now i will go a bit through the
technicalities of that
but i will go fast because it's kind of
really really the same story as flora
was saying on tuesday
except here it's a little not so simple
case
so going through the details would just
take probably the full two lectures so i
rather want to show you the results and
discuss
and but i will just go through it anyway
so the first thing to realize is that
when we are talking of generalization
error
i like to be talking about what's bias
optimum in the sense that no possible
algorithm could improve
on that and when you want to when you
want
bias optimal in the sense that no
algorithm can possibly improve
then you actually end up to be doing
something else than we usually are doing
in machine learning because in machine
learning we usually define some loss
function
and minimize it we do empirical risk
minimization
if you want the base optimal
generalization error
well that's not quite what you should do
although in 10 slides i will be
comparing to the erm so
hold tight if you're interested but what
you should do if you really want the
optimal error
you should write this posterior
distribution of what the w
what the weights are and then
when you're evaluating your labels
basically
your activation function on the scalar
product
of the weights some times your new
uh data so that you haven't seen in the
training set
then instead of plugging in the w that
you got by the minimization of some loss
function
what you should do you should average
over the posterior
you should average over the w with the
probability distribution that is the
posterior
and this if you if you estimate the
labels this way
then this is something that no other
algorithm can possibly improve
in in the setting we are talking about
so that's
the definition of the optimal
generalization here and that's what we
are
after and in order to compute it
we need to compute the replica symmetric
free energy which is just the logarithm
expectation of the logarithm of the
normalization here of the posterior
and after you know sitting with the
replica method for a day or two you can
get an
expression like this that the free
energy is a supremum over
m infimum over m head of an expression
of two scalar variables
which have you know one tribal term and
two terms that are some
pretty cryptic integrals
what what you want here is that your
problem was high dimensional pnn was
large and you know this combinatorial
space was just huge
but here you're optimizing just over
scalar order parameters
so you know writing it like this you
know it looks maybe impressing but it's
it's just a simple
scholar optimization problem so you can
just plug it in mathematica or anything
and
and plot it and see how it behaves
but this is not yet the generalization
error to get the generalization error
you need to actually evaluate
the m star and m hat star at which the
supremum is achieved
and plug it into this other expression
that is the expression for the
base of the maternalization error
so now to just give an idea of the proof
it really goes along the same lines of
what flora was explaining about the
interpolation
for the random vidizing model except
here
you need to be a bit it's it's less
direct and
and and you need to be careful but first
thing that really helps you
to understand this this expression where
it comes from
is realizing that these two terms that
are these kind of
expectations that on the first side
don't mean anything
that have a very very simple explicit
interpretation
that they are just the free energies of
scalar denoising problems two different
ones
so one of them is if you had some scalar
w star
that you multiply by this number and add
a noise
of at noise of zero mean and variance
one gaussian
and you measure this y hat then what is
in a sense the free energy or the mutual
information between this y hat and this
w
stop so this like if you understood
what's mutual information you just write
the integral of what it is and you get
exactly the expression from the previous
slide
and the same for this others color
denoising problem where you observe now
a variable z star plus noise through
this output channel
and so once you learn that then the
proof goes by the adaptive interpolation
method where you write
a hamiltonian that that depends on the
t here that we think of kind of an
interpolation
time and when this t is equal to
zero then you are back at the original
problem
and when the t is equal to one then the
original problem
is switched off is not there and you
just end up
adding p plus n of independence color
denoising problems from the previous
slide
so you write this kind of hamiltonian
and then
the the whole kind of art of the
interpolation
method is to actually show that you know
at t one you have something you know at
t zero you have what you want
and you need to show that as you change
t from
uh one to zero that the free energy is
not changing
and that's the whole that's the whole
core of the proof
and that's what has been done in this
paper and the kind of key property that
if you don't have the
the proof fails is is this nishimura
property or
or what you know what i call the base
optimality is in a sense that the
student knows what was the network that
the teacher was
choose using to generate the y's so
the activation is matched and all these
probability distributions are the right
ones
and if that's the case then you have a
symmetry a kind of a symmetry present in
that posterior measure that
sampling twice from the posterior
measure is kind of the same thing as
sampling once
and comparing to the ground true weights
and that's a kind of symmetry that in
the proof really simplify certain
expressions and make some formula that
otherwise would not be
a square square and that's why the proof
works if you go out of that
specific space where this condition
works then the proof com
falls apart and you know once you know
that then
it's just kind of just kind of hard work
to to get to the expression
so along the lines of what flora was
saying this is kind of non-constructive
information theoretic
results but let's connect to the
algorithms so
as usual there is a close connection to
this approximate message passing
algorithm that in this case
how do we derive it so this is just a
heuristic definition as we usually
do it in physics you take this graphical
model that corresponds to the posterior
distribution here
and you're right the belief propagation
for this graphical amount so this is
just straightforward
of course this is assuming by writing
the product here this is assuming that
the probabilities that correspond to
these messages are independent
which is something that you do but you
don't know whether this is true or
whether this is sufficiently true in
in the limit that you're taking and you
know this
is you know justifying it doesn't go
this way
but heuristically you can do that but
still you do that and then here you
realize that you have high dimensional
integral so this is still not tractable
this is not helping
but you also realize if you
look at this that that since you're
assuming that the incoming messages are
independent and there are many of them
because you have many neighbors then you
can basically call for the central limit
theorem and realize that certain things
are gaussian
and then instead of working with these
probability distributions you just work
with the means and variances of those
gaussians and you are actually able to
close the equations on those means and
variances
and if you do that that's what leads the
generalized approximate message passing
algorithm so the generalized here
stands for the fact that the p out
distribution was generic
if it was just a square then it would be
the
approximate message passing without the
g
and yeah i don't really want to be going
in details of these equations
uh just to say that you know
since when we were computing this
by um optimal generalization error
averaging over the posterior is
something
scary when you think about it in terms
of sampling but
that's also something that the
generalized approximate message passing
does for you like it just gives you the
prescription
for the distribution over which you
should average
to compute the optimal value of that new
label
if you actually had a new sample and so
within the algorithm there's just a very
very just one line of additional things
to compute those
optimal estimators of the labels
so what's really theoretically
interesting here
is that if you actually track what this
interactive algorithm is doing
you get the so-called state evolution
which can be stated
again using the very same expression
that before i was writing for the
replica symmetric free energy
so basically the state evolution is just
the gradient
ascend or decent depending when you put
the sign of this replica symmetric free
energy
and that that kind of connects the two
although
proving the state evolution doesn't go
at all through kind of
any anyway the replica solution that's
that's done differently and here i'm
just accounting
very selected set of of key references
on the approximate message passing so
where it comes from in physics and where
kind of it was revived
say 10 years ago and then these three
key references
where the proof of the state evolution
in the most generic setting that is
known can be
can be found and followed by
various collaborators of montanari
and so the bottom line here is that once
you have this replica
symmetric free energy you know a what is
information theoretically possible
from it and you know what the
approximate message passing algorithm
is getting from the same scalar
expression
so with that i go to kind of a set of
examples of what's going on and what we
know and what is interesting about it
so starting with the simplest case of
the spherical perceptron
but now the labels are created by the
teacher so we are not in the setting of
the storage capacity
so here the teacher weights were just
gaussians
and the labels were created just by
taking this color product and taking a
sign
so the simplest possible thing and now
the red line
that's the result of the optimal
generalization error as obtained from
the replica symmetric form
and then the black dots just to persuade
you numerically that this connection
between the approximate message passing
algorithm and the replica result
is correct so this is run on some maybe
10 000 dimensional system
and or maybe 1000 dimensional i don't
remember but you see that it kind of the
fluctuations are small and already for
those sizes
it's it's it looks like the asymptotic
prediction already kicked in that the
algorithm actually follows the
asymptotic line and then the blue
uh squares kind of interesting because
that's
the result of just logistic regression
as you would call it from scikit-learn
for this classification problem
so you just don't even think you just
take psychic learning you classify
this you know whatever is your data set
it will give you something and
this is the generalization error it
gives you so it's quite surprising that
it's really close
to actually the base optimal result
right the the logistic regression is
traditional and logistic loss
minimization
whereas the base optimal result is
sampling over all the
w's that are the same good as the true
one
and you see that the generalization
error is not quite yet close to zero
that means that there are many of them
that actually count so so we when
we actually oh here i'm just like
stating the difference what actually is
the difference between the base optimal
estimation we think the margins of the
posterior
and the empirical risk minimization
where we just define a loss
plus um plus the most common uh rich
uh regularization
and you know the probably simplest laws
would be the square loss but the
classification is most often solved with
the logistic loss
so that's how the logistic box looks
looks like
and what's actually interesting is that
this these two curves are so close that
it kind of inspired us to look into this
question more closely
also after realizing
some time ago maybe two years ago that
if you want to minimize a loss that is
convex such as the logistic or the
square laws
then we also have a proof technique then
of course we can write
the replica result for what the
generalization error of that is but
that's not rigorous
but we also have a proof technique of
how to prove that formula that goes
through the gordon minimax theory that
is kind of used
in many other works so so we applied it
recently to this particular case of the
spherical teacher student perceptron so
the setting is still the same
the black line that's still the same
that was the red line on the previous
image that's just a picture from a
different paper
and here the orange crosses
that's the result of the optimally
regularized logistic regression
so i choose the lambda the
regularization lambda optimally
with cross-validation or you know in the
theory i just minimized the error over
the lambda
and here you don't see any difference
it's just on the line but if you
actually plot the difference
you see that there is a difference that
the logistic regression is not
quite at the base optimal error but the
difference is
of 10 to the minus five and you know i i
bagged the student for about six weeks
that this actually must be zero
before he finally persuaded me that this
actually is not zero
so it's really really small but you know
for practical purposes
the optimally regularized logistic loss
here is reaching the base of the mole
error which is quite interesting
because it's kind of really doing
something very different
geometrically so
i yeah this also i i don't think this is
like widely known result
specular and just for comparison the
blue line here
is the evaluation of the rademacher
bound
because since we can compute the ground
state we can actually compute
what the rademacher bound is here is
telling it and you see
as in many other cases is very way off
the actual result but that's a very
specific setting so
that's not so surprising so going to the
binary perceptron now
so all i change here is that the teacher
now uses plus minus my one
man one weights teacher can use him
whatever he wishes
so that's how the picture looks like
so again the red line is the result of
the information theoretically optimal
error that you can achieve
at that ratio between number of samples
and dimension
the green line is the prediction of what
the approximate message passing
algorithm does
and again the black points is what it
actually does
and you see that it kind of follows what
it's supposed to be doing
but you see that there is this hard face
where it's not reaching what it
information theoretically could
and also you have the result of the
logistic regression here that is not
picking anything
interesting happening here it just keeps
decaying at its
you know at its rate but this kind of
closeness to the base optimal result is
kind of special to the spherical case so
when you start to put in some more
structure
you you know the teacher will speak
particular
of course the approximate message
passing is using that information
the logistic and the logistic regression
is not so
so so it's not so surprising that it's
not picking it
and regularizing it better is not
helping you would really have to do
something
else to kind of see something here
but this hard phase that's that's really
the same kind of hard phase as flora
was talking about yesterday in the
stochastic block model
so there is this big question i'm not
really setting this is an open problem
because i think this
is really like we all know and it's too
hard you know is
is there a polynomial algorithm that
recovers the signal
in at least part of the heart phase so
so that's kind of
you know i don't have a 1 million dollar
to give to somebody if they solve it but
otherwise it would be a 1 billion dollar
quest
so this is a another variant that i
picked here particularly for alex wayne
i hope he's there because we discussed
in the gather town like
yesterday or the day before so here
again the teacher weights are binary but
now i am changing slightly the
activation function so i'm taking still
a sign
but this time of the absolute value of
this color product minus
some constant k that i choose in such a
way that half
the k is chosen in such a way that half
of the y's are plus one and half of them
are minus
just to keep kind of that symmetry i
call this the symmetric door perceptron
what's interesting about it is that
when when i am not generalizing
perfectly
i'm actually not doing better as than
random guess
so right in the
i just go back here here the error was
better than one
meaning that i was doing better than
randomly guessing who is in which group
here the error is one it means you know
it's normalized in such a way that this
is as bad as random guess
and then there is the hard phase between
the information theoretically optimal
performance and what the
approximate message passing is doing
with
a uh with with
a actually here it's one up to a certain
point
and then it's slightly smaller than one
and then it jumps
to zero so why is this interesting
so this is this open problem number two
particularly for alex
so can one prove that the sos lower
bound for this problem
that the sos gives a lower bound for
this problem because alex was kind of
telling me that that for the generalized
linear regression
type problems these techniques were not
applied because there were not cases
where
the where the detection problem would be
actually hard but if you change the
activation function
like here i think this could be an
interesting problem to look at
in in this amount so open problem number
two
tell it if you're listening note it
somewhere in the
list so so far these three
problems i mentioned were all
classification problems the y was always
plus
minus one there was some sign somewhere
the teacher was using a sign somewhere
so now i go to a regression where
y will be real valued so the you know
here is one my slide back about the
compressed sensing so that's that's the
kind of
case of sparse linear regression that is
that was very
widely studied and here i'm just showing
a picture that comes from
a different paper but it just directly
falls into the setting of this
generalized linear model
i just need to take the distribution the
teacher uses gauss bernoulli
distribution and the student as well
and again i have the phase diagram
depending on the sparsity of the signal
and this
alpha which is still the number of
samples divided by the dimension
i have a phase where recovering the
signal is impossible or hard or easy if
you do it with the amp
or easy if you do it with l1
regularization
so the the so this one is kind of
well known and you can go in the in the
lead directory if you are not familiar
with it
but but this one is slightly less
well-known and i think it's really
interesting
is what happens if you do the same thing
but
the teacher actually takes the absolute
value of the product so it loses the
signs
so you would think that you know since y
is real value
losing the sine information
theoretically you should not be losing
basically anything and that's actually
the case
the information theoretic phase
transition that is the black line here
is exactly the same as if you didn't
have the absolute value so that
intuition about the information theory
working
properly is is correct but if you look
at it
from the computational perspective if
you look at the performance of the
approximate message passing and
i didn't mention it but we kind of you
know we i didn't mention it right we
don't know of other algorithms that
would be better
so if you look how that performs in this
case
you actually get the red line that
is telling you that below the red line
you're not algorithmically able to
recover the vector w star
and notably as the this is sparse
phase retrieval so rho is the number of
non-zeros
so notably as the raw is getting smaller
and information theoretically you would
also need fewer and fewer samples or
measurements
actually algorithmically you saturate at
half you're not able to
beat half so that means that you know if
you lost the science unit you cannot
sense compressive
at least in this specific setting you
may be in gen
of course for instance if the raw is so
small that it's not extensive anymore
with the dimension or the number of
samples
then you know if i kind of zoomed here
then this is going back to zero and
that's kind of what some of the
with probably most of the literature on
a sparse phase retrieval is about
but if you go to the sparsity that is
some fraction of the dimension then this
is what you get
and this is just the same picture but
this time
for rho equal one so this time i'm not
even sparse the teacher is just using a
gaussian vector
and and this is the mean square error
that you get which is related to the
generalization error it has the same
shape
and you see that information
theoretically just having more samples
than the dimension would be enough as
the orange line
but algorithmically you need slightly
more something like 13 percent more
and there again is this hard phase where
we don't know if algorithms working and
so this is just to show you that the
heart phase exists in the generalized
linear model you don't need to be
classifying
it exists in regression models and you
don't need to be sparse it exists
also for the signals that are actually
gaussian so
so you really kind of if you want to
find it you find it everywhere
so here i am coming slowly to towards
the end of the today's lecture so i just
want to recap here
for the from the rigorous point of view
where we are
so so the example one
two and three were all cases where the
uh where the x is iid and the prior on
the w
is separable iid and
in these cases we kind of have the proof
of the replica formula
settled in two cases so so
non-rigorously we have the replica
formula in that case generic
sometimes there would be replica
symmetry breaking so we need to take
care of that but
that in principle you know we can write
the formulas
so this can be done in the non-bias
optimal in the non-convex like
any setting as long as these two
conditions are
are fine then generically we have the
formula
but rigorously we only have it in the
base optimal case
that is for the teacher that is matching
the student kind of the posterior
matches the generative
process so there was this this paper
that i talked about
and we also have it via the gordon mini
max theory
for the empirical risk minimization if
the loss function is convex
but out of that we don't know how to
prove the formula
even when the replica symmetric one is
predicted to be correct
so that would be open problem three for
this
for any case with gaussian iid
data x and separable prior can you prove
that the
even the replica symmetric formula is
for the free energy is correct
for any setting that goes away from
these two ones so that is non-convex
and non-biosoft so
again i i think you know this is a white
space there should be some cases
where things are possible surely
somewhere at
a high temperature high noise limit one
can do something and
you know probably there even are things
in that limit and you
can can one kind of cut the space where
we don't know how to prove things
i think we could talk about that
in open problem number three and that's
it for today
so tomorrow we will be adding hidden
variables and hidden layers
and making the x non-iid and making the
w non-separable
but for today i think that's
that's all
okay thank you so much lenka uh we there
are some questions in the chat
uh adam can you unmute yourself to ask
oh yeah i was just wondering um what
happens if you plot
kind of the error if you run a very
simple averaging algorithm
that's known to kind of work for
learning a perceptron when x is iid
gaussian
and also what happens if the threshold
for the
half space is non-zero
so when you run averaging algorithm you
mean for the
for the when the labels are random
or for the teacher student case so i
mean for the teacher student case
if x is iid gaussian one thing you can
do is just look at all of the points
that are labeled plus one and take the
center of math of those points
and just output yeah sure so so that
will give you some error that will be
you know at best the same as the one of
the approximate message passing but
probably
quite a bit worse
and there was a second part to your
question oh yeah just what happens um
if the threshold is non-zero
oh if the threshold is non-zero so
that's in the storage capacity case
so yeah that so so it's pretty much the
same as for the threshold zero
at least from the kind of status point
of view
the know the for instance the
frozen one rsb is still there and
yeah the the heuristic results exist and
are out there for all values of the
threshold
from the math point of view
it depends so it depends what you mean
what happens in which case
um
i was yeah thinking about the plot of
the error for the learning case
also the learning case but then the
threshold
like would the teacher be using the
threshold or notes
yeah the teacher uses the threshold oh
okay
yeah so that would be another case that
you could evaluate so i don't
have like that's plotted
i don't know okay
there are thanks questions could you
summarize when
ideas from statistical physics have led
to improved performance of machine
learning algorithms
on practical problems never have
ideas from statistical physics being
applied in reinforcement i mean if
practically you mean something like i
don't know google translation
then you know we are not there yet and
then there is a question
by anna thomas
i have ideas from statistical physics
being applied in reinforcement learning
or causal inference
so i haven't
used i haven't worked on reinforcement
learning or causal interference myself
that doesn't mean that
other people were not surely they were
but i'm not like very familiar with
those works
i mean there are some yeah
i can point you to some references but i
there are some works now yes so so the
answer would be yes
but to give some summary of what
interesting things have been found i
i would have to take that offline
so can i add one thing i think um
some some of the tools are conceptually
useful in the sense that like
a lot of people in ml care about the
notion of like flat minimum
so i'd say some of the ideas that come
up in you know bayesian kinds of
inference about what kinds of
yeah i know i'm cool i just don't like
that kind of question
i guess i mean
i mean you know it's it's as with all
you know fundamental theory and
fundamental math right
you learn more about these things and
eventually and eventually they
they percolate to the practice but often
it's even like hard to trace how exactly
and
and i think when you start making
stories how exactly and what was
important then others can say that
something else was more important than
this actually didn't matter
there will be again for offline
discussion that i am happy to have
especially with you or whoever asked the
question
i think my summary that like none is
pretty the most
just but maybe maybe you disagree
i i have a quick question so in in
i think all the models you presented
today you do inference
assuming you do inference in the same
model that
uh the data is generated from so um
if you have like just a small mismatch
between the
the model and the if you have a small
mismatch between the inference and the
model that it comes from do you still
have the
replica symmetry yes yes so
so the replica symmetry is there on the
quite broad condition like
you know one example would be when you
the empirical risk minimization
than for instance obviously for the
convex losses you still have replica
symmetry and that's if you think about
it as a mismatch of the model
and the loss that's kind of hugely
mismatched
but quite generically as we we actually
can
can put these phase diagrams where we
kind of expect that the replica symmetry
breaks and usually there is a
huge chunk of the mismatched
if you kind of imagine one axis how much
it was mismatched
there is a huge chunk of that phase
diagram that stays replica symmetric and
we can
so so always for instance it is
when the noise is bigger than the base
optimal noise then it's always replica
symmetric we like don't know or maybe
there would be some
specifically constructed country
examples where you have some kind of
re-entrance
but in kind of all the kind of natural
examples where we looked at it you don't
have this kind of
re-entrance so for that open problem in
particular for instance showing that
if i think of the base optimal case as
temperature one
showing that at any temperature bigger
than one the replica asymmetric formula
is still correct this i'm pretty
confident is true under some
very broad condition but i have no idea
how to
do it
if there are other questions feel free
to raise your hand or type it into the q
a
okay so then uh wait we thank lanka
again for her talk and
we'll meet back here in 25 minutes for
ankara's talk and right now we have a
coffee break on the gather town
thanks